el corazón bombea sangre al cuerpo y
bombea con tanta fuerza que expulsa
parte del fluido que va por los
capilares fuera de ellos y ese fluido se
vuelve linfa el sistema linfático
recupera todo ese fluido y lo lleva de
regreso a la circulación esta idea
quizás los desconcierta porque estos
vasos linfáticos no tienen un corazón
propio no lo dibuje porque no lo tienen
como es posible que puedan enviar el
fluido en una sola dirección y más aún
cómo es que pueden regresar el fluido a
este sistema de alta presión dado que no
tienen corazón eso debe ser difícil hay
dos respuestas para esto la primera es
más sencilla por lo que comenzamos con
ella la primera respuesta está en la
ubicación de reentrada la razón por la
que la linfa puede regresar al sistema
de alta presión es porque la linfa es
muy inteligente con respecto a por dónde
tratar de volver a entrar al sistema
dibujó una estrella aquí porque es el
punto por donde regresa la linfa y no lo
dibuje por accidente regresa en la
última parte del sistema de circulación
venoso
aquí es mucho menor que la presión en
las arterias e incluso menor que la
presión en los capilares los números son
reveladores la presión aquí al principio
de las arterias es de 120 milímetros de
mercurio que es la presión arterial
promedio pero por aquí justo antes de
que regrese al corazón la presión es de
5 milímetros de mercurio el hecho de que
el fluido linfático entre a la
circulación aquí al final lo hace más
fácil ya que tiene que luchar menos si
los vasos linfáticos trataran de drenar
aquí en la aorta o en otra arteria
grande probablemente nada de esto
funcionaría esto facilita el trabajo
pero no explica cómo es que la linfa se
mueve en una sola dirección hacia los
vasos sanguíneos qué es lo que hace que
la linfa se mueva en esta dirección
porque no regresa una parte así como una
parte avanza la razón por la que hace
esto es debido a las válvulas las
válvulas son estructuras dentro de los
vasos linfáticos que evitan que el flujo
regrese por donde venía vamos a dibujar
un vaso linfático aquí una válvula luce
más
- así lo que logra esta válvula es que
si el fluido empuja de este lado va a
separar las dos cúspides de la válvula y
la va a atravesar pero digamos que el
fluido trata de regresar por lo que
empuja las cúspides de la válvula desde
el otro lado lo que hace que éstas se
cierren y creen un obstáculo este es un
sistema muy inteligente que de hecho no
solo se usa en el sistema linfático
también es usado en el corazón hay
cuatro válvulas grandes en el corazón
que operan con este mismo principio y
también se usa en las venas porque la
presión para llevar el fluido por las
venas a veces no es suficiente por lo
que tener un mecanismo que evite que
regrese el fluido es muy útil pero quizá
esto aún no lo satisfaga del todo pues
que es lo que ocasiona que el fluido se
mueva aquí porque no se queda estancado
en dónde está de hecho hay dos formas en
las que comienza el movimiento una es
que tenemos una parte de músculo suave
anexado a los vasos linfáticos lo que
hace que se puedan contraer y con sólo
apretar hace que se mueva el fluido
hacia
este es el primer mecanismo que hace que
el fluido se comience a mover el segundo
mecanismo es el músculo esquelético esto
se refiere a todos los grandes músculos
en el cuerpo que están bajo control
voluntario como los músculos de los
brazos y de las piernas
etcétera y la razón por la que esto hace
algo es porque en el transcurso del día
usamos los músculos para movernos
realizamos cierta cantidad de movimiento
por lo que es inevitable que extraemos
algunas partes del cuerpo en
determinados momentos y cuando
estrujamos una parte del cuerpo que
tiene vasos linfáticos como este va a
iniciar su movimiento va a exprimirlo
como lo hace el músculo suave por lo que
tenemos fluido en movimiento con la
dirección permitida por las válvulas
además de las válvulas que dibujamos
aquí hay una estructura interesante por
donde la linfa entra a los vasos
linfáticos aquí lo dibujé como un tubo
abierto pero en realidad parece estar
cerrado aunque es poroso y por eso
permite que entre el fluido voy a
dibujar esto más grande básicamente es
aquí
donde comienza el vaso linfático las
paredes de este vaso linfático son como
pequeñas válvulas en sí mismas permiten
que entre el fluido pero cuando aumenta
la presión interna evita que el fluido
salga del vaso finalmente veamos el
cuerpo humano para darnos una idea de en
donde se ubica esto de nuevo dibujo una
figura humana medio fea y ahora podemos
mostrar por dónde regresa la linfa a la
circulación digamos que este es el
corazón y quizás sepan que una de las
venas más grandes que llegan al corazón
es la vena cava superior y justo cerca
de la vena cava superior tenemos lo que
llamamos las venas subclavias tenemos
una a la izquierda y otra a la derecha
se llaman venas subclavias porque se
encuentran por debajo de las clavículas
y es por estas venas que vuelve a entrar
la linfa dibujo esto en verde que
corresponde a esto en este punto tenemos
muy poca presión y es aquí a donde llega
toda la linfa del cuerpo lo que incluye
la linfa que viene de las piernas de los
brazos del
etcétera todo esto es impresionante el
que toda la linfa del cuerpo recorra
todo este camino para ser devuelta a la
circulación aquí todo esto realizado sin
una bomba en particular solamente usando
este método de exprimir o estrujar el
músculo suave pero sobre todo es gracias
a estas sencillas válvulas
unidireccionales que aprovechan que
siempre nos estamos moviendo lo que hace
que se aprieten estos vasos y se lleve
toda la linfa del cuerpo a esencialmente
el cuello